Wir wollen mal wieder auf die 2. Liga der Männer blicken und da haben wir euch heute eine tolle Runde mitgebracht. Wir werden sprechen über Hertha BSC, über Hannover 96 und über Holstein Kiel und das Ganze tun wir mit Pike, mit Ansgar Löcke und mit Jan Müller-Reichenwallner. Und genau jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Und das an Zunung. Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Leute, ich sag's euch, wie es ist. Ich hab Bock. Wir werden sprechen über die 2. Liga. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, was wir heute alles so aufdecken werden. Aber erstmal begrüße ich nochmal meine Runde bei mir. Zum einen natürlich Pike ist dabei von 1912 FM. Servus, Pike. Schön, dass du da bist. Ansgar Löcke ist hier von Niemals weiter – nein, Moment mal. Wie heißt dein aktuelles Format, Ansgar, wo man dich hören kann?
Jetzt hast du jetzt gerade Pikes Aufstieg getingst.
Stimmt, dann habe ich gleich drüber nachgedacht. Ich sage gar nichts mehr voraus in der 2. Liga. Aber dieses Problem mit den Gästen, die man hat, mit der Auswahl an Gästen, und dass man sehr, sehr gut Sendung machen kann, das habe ich ja auch bei Hertha WSC. Aber da, lieber Jan, da will ich jetzt die Aufstiegsfrage gar nicht stellen. Aus guten Gründen. Hertha liegt auf Rang 11. 34 Punkte hat man, damit hat man 7 Punkte nach oben auf den HSV. Man hat 9 Punkte nach unten auf Hansa Rostock aktuell. Und ich würde die These in den Raum stellen, oder dir zum Fraß vorwerfen, dass die 9 Punkte nach unten gerade die beste Nachricht sind. Weil bei allem, was schon passiert ist bei Hertha in dieser Saison, gab es mehrmals die Chance, dass man richtig, richtig nach unten durchrauscht. Aber danach sieht es jetzt gerade nicht aus, oder?
Wir sind Rückrunden 16. Also kannst du draus machen, was du möchtest. Aber es sieht schon nicht so rosig aus, würde ich sagen. Unter dem Eindruck des Aushaltspiels bei St. Pauli.
Okay, also, ja, hast du natürlich recht. Also erst zwei Siege, drei Unentschieden jetzt in der Rückrunde. Und da sind ja auch schon acht Partien gespielt. Aber dass man ja trotzdem noch neun Punkte Vorsprung hat, zeigt ja, die da unten stellen sich ja halt mal wieder an. Und vor allem, weil eben so Teams wie Braunschweig und Rostock angefangen haben zu punkten, haben die sich auch gegenseitig Punkte weggenommen. Schalke ist seine, seine ganze Schalkehaftigkeit wieder ein einziges, ein einziges, es gibt doch bei den Simpsons diese Reifenmüllhalde, die einfach ganzjährig brennt. Und das ist ja Schalke 04 im Grunde. Also das heißt ja, Rückrunde natürlich nicht gut. Musst du mir auch gleich erklären, warum. Aber trotzdem ist man ja noch nicht so richtig da unten reingerückt. Ist das nicht, also vielleicht versuche ich auch gerade, dir nur positive Dinge hinzuwerfen, an denen du dich aufrichten kannst. Du sollst ja durch den Tag kommen. Aber man kann es doch auch positiv deuten.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das Team hat einfach im Dezember gepiekt. Und seitdem geht es irgendwie stetig ein bisschen weiter bergab.
Aber warum? Woran liegt das?
Du hast zum ersten Mal im Sommer 30 Transferbewegungen gehabt. Du hast keine richtige Mannschaft zusammen. Dann ist der wichtigste Spieler Reese im Dezember ausgefallen mit Corona. Er war längere Zeit nicht dabei. Da gab es dann wunderbare Spiele wie das 0-0 gegen Osnabrück, bevor die angefangen haben, gut zu. Spielen. Jetzt stellt man sich die Frage, ob es eine weitere Entwicklung unter Dada gibt. Als der Kader durcheinander war und man drei Spiele mit 0-5 Toren verloren hat, gab es eine bessere Entwicklung. Dann haben sich leider die Kreativspieler alle auf einmal verletzt. Duziak hat jetzt eine Halbzeit gespielt und seitdem nicht mehr. Wenn man den Anfang der Saison und den Anfang der Rückrunde guckt, ist das alles sehr ähnlich.
Ja, aber zum Anfang der Rückrunde immerhin einen Punkt aus den ersten drei Spielen geholt und nicht null Punkte aus den ersten drei Spielen. War es nicht so? Eine leichte Verbesserung. Aber das mit den vielen Transfers, das ist ja klar. Wir alle haben mitbekommen, wie dieser Umbruch bei Hertha war. Und dann Marco Richter noch weg und so weiter und so fort. Aber das kann ja nicht der Grund sein, dass man quasi zu viel Veränderungen hatte. Und jetzt im Winter fällt es ihnen auf. Oh, wir kennen uns ja alle gar nicht. Wir spielen jetzt auf einmal schlechter. Könnte es nicht vielleicht auch eher sein, dass man es ja dann doch geschafft hat, einen Fußball zu etablieren, der Erfolg hatte, mit dem man zumindest lange nicht verloren hat. Das war ja eigentlich so dann die Kernkompetenz von Hertha irgendwann. Es war nicht immer schön. Man hat auch nicht immer gewonnen, eher seltener sogar. Aber du hast halt nie verloren. Ist es vielleicht möglich, dass sich die Gegner besser darauf eingestellt haben? Weil ich habe jetzt nicht so viel von Hertha gesehen. Aber wenn ich Dinge von Hertha gesehen habe, dann war, wenn nicht gerade Fabian Reese am Ball war, war es ehrlich gesagt immer das Gleiche, hatte ich das Gefühl.
Ja, und es ist halt eben wirklich nur der Pass von hinten raus auf Fabian Reese, er geht auf den Flügel. Es gibt Ansätze in anderen Spielen, wo es dann wie gegen Magdeburg total super läuft. Er geht dabei vom Innenverteidiger gleich nach vorne, was man auch von Hertha gar nicht mehr so kennt. Irgendwie ein schönes Spiel. Aber jetzt, wo halt die Leute wissen, wir machen Reese zu, passiert nichts, ist bei Kiel so gewesen. Der hat nicht viel gemacht. Und jetzt auf St. Pauli war auch nichts zu sehen. Dann ist es halt alles ein bisschen, es ist ja immer noch Dadai-Ball. Dadai war erst nicht früher auch immer so, hinten gut stehen und vorne hilft der liebe Gott oder wieder die Bischewitsch jetzt in den letzten Jahren.
Ja, aber Dadai-Ball ist so lustig, dass wir jetzt in der 2. Liga immer vom Wall dabei, vom Dadai-Ball und so weiter sprechen. Aber wenn wir das mal so bezeichnen wollen, dann kennzeichnet dies ja auch. Also klar, defensive Stabilität, aber ja auch ein sehr, sehr hoher Laufaufwand. Eigentlich eine relativ gute Intensität in den Zweikämpfen. Und es ist eben einfach sehr unangenehm, gegen Hertha zu spielen. Wenn ich die jetzt aber so zuhöre und wenn ich mir auch die Ergebnisse angucke, eben in Braunschwalk 1 zu 1, dann eben das jetzt schon öfter zitierte 2 zu 2 gegen Kiel und jetzt zuletzt gegen St. Pauli. Gut, da haben schon andere verloren. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass das vor allem fehlt, dass es nicht mehr unangenehm ist, gegen Hertha zu spielen.
Das Problem bei St. Pauli ist ja nicht die Niederlage. Es ist ja, wie du verloren hast. Du hast in der ersten Halbzeit überhaupt keinen Stich, denn in der zweiten war es dann ein bisschen besser. Du warst niemals da dran, wirklich ein wirkliches Tor zu schießen, so etwas in die Richtung. Und Hertha ist ja auch irgendwie, erzählt ja jeder Reporter, der als allererstes, wenn es anfängt, ja, erster Halbzeit Meister. Und danach dann spiele man auch unentschieden oder verloren.
Also ein Konditionsproblem, jetzt haben wir es doch.
Nein, es ist kein Konter. Es ist einfach ein mentales Problem, weil er das, glaube ich, seit Jahren gibt. Auch so wie wir haben eine Chance, etwas Gutes zu machen. Halbfinale, Pokal 2016 gegen Dortmund, 0 zu 3 verloren und absolut nichts gebracht. Jetzt im Achtelfinale den HSV auf besondere Art und Weise das Spiel noch gewonnen und dann bist du gegen Lautern dran und auch so ein absoluter Rock-Krepierer. Vor allem so, wie Lautern jetzt die ganze Zeit spielt, ist ja nicht so, dass die jetzt dann noch irgendwie sich in den Aufstieg eingeschaltet haben. Man fragt sich jetzt, hat sich das Spielsystem entwickelt und ist er der Richtige, um die Mannschaft dann mit einer Weiterentwicklung nächstes Jahr zum Aufstieg zu bringen oder nicht? Und da ist man sich gerade nicht so sicher.
Nächstes Jahr steigt doch Hannover auf. Hey, ihr könnt jetzt nicht alle sagen, wir steigen nächstes Jahr auf. Ihr müsst euch da auch besser anwenden.
Es ist alternativlos, tut mir leid. Du hattest halt früher einen Rainer Wiedmeier als Co-Trainer, der immer nachgesagt wurde, er wäre der Taktikfuchs gewesen in dieser Verbindung. Und wie es jetzt mit Tamas Bodok läuft, da ist man sich nicht ganz so sicher. Und ich war eigentlich relativ okay, ist ja ganz nett. Also im Grunde, vielleicht so ein Jahr davor, ist es eigentlich traumhaft ruhig und nett. Aber nach oben wird es gerade nicht gehen. Und jetzt ist ein bisschen diese Katerstimmung da. Okay, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Ja, gerade das, dieses Ruhige. Ich verfolge Hertha jetzt ja auch nur als Außenstehender. Aber für mich kommt es auch so darüber, als wenn gefühlt alle cool damit sind, dass Hertha im grauen Mittelfeld der 2. Liga diese Saison ist. Also klar ist irgendwie so die Abstiegssaison, aber trotzdem wird man ja irgendwie gerade auch so als Fan gedacht haben, gut, wir spielen zumindest irgendwie um den Aufstieg wieder mit. Aber nach außen, finde ich, wirkt es so, als wenn alle damit fein sind, dass Hertha so absolut gar keine Rolle in der 2. Und das erstaunt mich dann doch irgendwie.
Naja, also ich war auf der Milchdorfversammlung nach dem Abstieg aus der 1. Liga und das war eine der ruhigsten MVs, auf denen ich je gewesen bin. Da war ich dazu so, okay, also es gab MVs, da ist Hertha 10. geworden oder ganz knapp Europa verpasst mit Dada und danach war viel mehr Stress als auf diesen MVs. Und es ist wahrscheinlich dieser Demutsgedanke, den Kai Bernstein damit eingebracht hat und der leider nicht überall ankommt, aber der, glaube ich, ganz wichtig ist für Hertha in den nächsten Jahren.
Ja, aber da sind wir ja schon bei einem Thema, also wenn du sagst, es ist vor allem ein mentales Thema. Also es ist ja wirklich, ich meine, du kannst es jetzt nicht mehr hören, aber ich möchte es nochmal wiederholen für die Hörerinnen und Hörer. Nach der Tabelle der ersten Hälfte, da hat Hertha BSC mit 47 Punkten die meisten aller Zweitligesten, dass man Tabellenführer und dementsprechend schlecht ist es in der zweiten Hälfte und du hast schon gesagt, kein konditionelles Problem, sondern ein mentales Problem. Müssen wir dann auch den Tod von Karl Bernstein und alles, was dann quasi wie so ein Mühlstein auf der Rückrunde auf einmal lag, müssen wir das da mitbeachten?
Und ich habe jetzt immer mal überlegt, wie es gewesen wäre, wenn der vorherige Präsident einer Gegenbauer plötzlich verstorben wäre. Und ich glaube, das hätte kein Groß gejuckt, um es mal so ganz gemein zu sagen. Es war ein riesengroßes Ding, das immer noch auf einem hängt. Zumal ja auch zum ersten Mal nach Jahren der Misswirtschaft und der neuesten Pleiten Pech und Pannen und immer mehr Verlusten. Ich habe das vorhin nochmal nachgeguckt. Hertha hatte früher einen Aufwand von 62 Millionen beim Personal. Der ging dann auf einmal hoch auf 80. Da war Klingsmann. Dann kam Bobic. Dann war er bei 92 und bei 97. Du hast einen Verlustvortrag insgesamt von 447 Millionen, wenn ich alles zusammengerechnet habe. Dann wird 2026 und 2025 die 40-Millionen-Anleihe wieder fällig. Mit der haben sie nur die Lizenz bekommen, weil sie diese Anleihe um zwei Jahre verlängert haben. Die war eigentlich dieses Jahr fällig, aber das Geld war absolut nicht da. Der Verein hat sich schon sehr grundlegend verändert. Das höre ich von Leuten, die seit 20, 30 Jahren bei Hertha arbeiten. Es ist ein neuer Geist, und da ist dann alles auf einmal total zum Erliegen gekommen. Wenn Kai Bernstein jetzt noch leben würde, würde es mir um einiges besser gehen im Gesamtausblick auf die Zukunft von Hertha BSC.
Es ist jetzt reine Spekulation, aber das muss man doch fast auch auf dem Feld sehen, weil es ja quasi direkt auch unmittelbar vor Start der Rückrunde war. Ich habe mir das zum Beispiel bei diesem Ausschalten gegen Kaiserslautern gedacht, auf dem ja so ein unglaublicher Druck war, weil das das große Ziel ist von Hertha BSC. Und weil Pardada ja auch der Trainer ist, der das immer wieder und wieder gesagt hat, das ist mein Traum, ich will mal im Olympiastadion im Finale stehen. Und Kai Bernstein hat das auch sehr offensiv formuliert. Und es musste ja fast scheitern, weil das war quasi in dieser Situation vor einem ausverkauften Haus dann mit ja auch, keine Ahnung, 30.000 Lauterern oder so was. Das war ja quasi schon wie so ein Finale und das geht hat dann auch oft verloren. Weil man sowas noch nicht so oft durch erlebt hat. Also würdest du jetzt dann quasi sagen, wir können das mit reinnehmen und können sagen, diese sportliche Misere, die aber sehr wahrscheinlich hoffentlich nicht in einem Abstieg münden wird, weil dafür hat man eben noch genügend Polster, obwohl man jetzt wirklich eine schlechte Rückrunde spielt, dass es eben auch daher kommen kann, dass man eben so seinen einen ganz besonderen Moment hatte, der den ganzen Verein belastet.
Ja, es ist halt sehr diffus und ich weiß nicht genau, wiefern jetzt ein Eimann Barcock, der hier ankommt aus Mainz und dann zwei Tage vorher ist der Präsident gestorben, wie die Leute das betrifft. Aber er war schon nah dran, mehr dran als viele andere. Das ist aber auch jetzt, klingt alles immer ein Dade, der sagt, keiner ausreden. Zu dem Tod kam er noch hinzu, dass du an diese Krankheitswelle hattest, dass ganz viele Leute auch in diesem Spiel nicht spielen konnten. Dann war er der Reese, der überhaupt das Achtelfinale erst gewonnen hat. Quasi immer Leingang mit zwei Toren, einem Assist, dem entscheidenden Elfmeter. Und da hast du, glaube ich, du hast einfach alles Glück in diesem Spiel verbraucht. Und das kommt dann nicht mehr wieder. Abstieg sollte man nicht aus dem Auge lassen. Ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass es passiert. Man muss jetzt nur nach vorne schauen, was man als nächstes macht. Also, dass Fabian Rees überhaupt verlängert hat, ist ja schon mal ein ganz großes Ding. Jetzt geistern gerade die neuen Sachen durch. Was ist mit den jungen Leuten? Und einer der Bänzer da, der der jüngste Sohn von Pall Dada, der soll bei Wolfsburg unterschrieben haben. Was mir ein bisschen mehr Sorgen macht, ist Berliner Weg. Wurde ja ausgerufen, wir machen was ganz Neues, wir arbeiten mit jungen Spielern. Und da hat die U23, die hat losgelegt wie die Feuerwehr, die haben noch nie so gut gespielt. Das Stadion war wirklich voll, sonst waren da, wenn es hochkommt, 200, 300 Leute, auf einmal war das wirklich knackeknacke voll. Und die sind da durchmarschiert. Und ich glaube, wir sind hier auf dem 15. Platz, haben das letzte Spiel. Da haben sie zwar gegen Greifswald gespielt, die Tabellenführer sind, haben aber auch mit vielen Profis es nicht geschafft, dieses Spiel zu gewinnen und haben dann 0-1 verloren. Und wie es in der Akademie weitergeht und was sich da entwickelt, ist ein bisschen auch eine Frage. Das ist nämlich das jetzt, was das einzige Fausthorn, was Hertha noch hat, ist, die Akademie. Und wenn jetzt da Leute weggehen, dann macht man sich ein bisschen Sorgen ums Ganze.
Gut, ich meine, da gab es ja auch schon ein bisschen Wechsel. Michael Hartmann zum Beispiel, langjähriger U19-Trainer, ist zu dem Bayern an Campus gewechselt. Und gleichzeitig gab es aber auch die größere Aufmerksamkeit. Ich habe gerade den Namen vergessen, welcher Spieler war der, der auch so viele Follower hat und quasi Influencer ist. Das hat natürlich auch dafür gesorgt, also ja mit fast schon chaotischen Zuständen inzwischen zeitlich, aber dass da eben erhöhter Fokus drauf war. Hertha ist gerade so in der Schwebe. Und die Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe, weil bei vielen Dingen, da wissen wir jetzt nicht, wie es sich weit entwickelt. Also kann man den Berliner Weg, den Kai Bernstein eingeschlagen ist? Wer sich dafür interessiert, habe ich ja in einem Tribüngespräch nochmal ausführlich versucht, nachzuzeichnen. Kann man den weiterführen? Wissen wir nicht. Es hing sehr an seine Person. Mal sehen. Es gibt natürlich Leute, die er auch installiert hat, die in seinem Sinne handeln. Aber ob das so hinhaut, werden wir sehen. Ähnliches ist es mit dem Kader, dass es da eine Fluktuation geben kann. Das ist fast gegeben. Wenn du viel Talent hast, und das ist ja quasi was Besonderes im Hertha-BSC-Kader, dann wird man da auch viel verlieren. Das haben wir vorhin bei Kiel letztlich auch besprochen, wie das eben einfach so eine Normalität ist, dass die besten Spieler dann oft doch leider wieder gehen. Wo ich allerdings so ein komplett großes Fragezeichen habe, ist bei Pahl Darday, den wir schon 30 Mal, ich runde jetzt ab, als Trainer gesehen haben, also in 30 einzelnen Laufzeiten, die er da zuständig war, wo sich auf eine positive Art und Weise nie was verändert hat. Er war immer gleich als Pahl Darday, wo man aber auch manchmal gemerkt hat, so im zweiten Jahr, dass dieses Immer-Gleich-Sein manchmal auch so einen Abnutzungseffekt hat. Und man sich so gedacht hat, ja, haben wir jetzt alles schon mal gehört und den Fußball kennen wir jetzt auch inzwischen. Kann es sein, dass sich auch gerade seine Figur und wie er gesehen wird im Hertha-Umfeld ändert, weil er es eben auch nicht schafft, Hertha aus dieser – na, lethargie ist zu viel, aber aus diesem Schwebezustand heraus zu bekommen. Und das war ja genau seine Kernkompetenz, die er bisher immer drauf hatte. Hol Pahl und er rettet das alles, er kriegt das irgendwie hin und beim Abstieg kam sehen, er hat einfach zu spät geholt.
Na ja, er hat ja schon was geleistet. Also was im Sommer da passiert ist, das war ja wirklich – ich meine, du hast einen Spieler wie Luka Tuzar geholt für 25 Millionen, der ging dann für 1, 2 zum Stadtrivalen. Und dann da aus diesem Haufen – ich meine, er hat im Grunde den Kader fertig gehabt nach drei Spieltagen. Und dann lief das eigentlich super. Und ich glaube, hätten sich dann nicht zum Beispiel sein Sohn verletzt, dann hätte das sich auch jetzt spielerisch etwas weiterentwickeln können. Jetzt bist du halt – es gibt Leute, die stimmen mehr in sich, da, der raus, da, der raus. Im Grunde ist die Person, Pall Dadaj – bei Hertha, der kann sich nichts mehr einreißen. Der könnte morgen zu Union wechseln, als Trainer mit dem Deutscher Meister werden. Das würde ihm nix anhaben, also er hat halt sein Denkmal. Was mich freuen würde, wenn man es mal schaffen würde, sich von ihm jetzt zu trennen. Dass man sagt, okay, wir machen nicht weiter, dann geht er in die Akademie, vielleicht als Akademieleiter, und dann geht es einfach weiter mit einem neuen Trainer. Ich glaube nicht, dass er sich viel kaputt machen kann, aber er wird ein bisschen dünnhäutiger wieder in den Interviews, habe ich das Gefühl. Mit der Medien-Schälte ist die Presse angefangen, hätte vom Aufstieg zu reden. Andererseits läuft auch vieles gut, ich bin jetzt auch vielleicht ein bisschen negativ, aber es gibt zum Beispiel Sachen wie diese interne Doku, die gemacht wird. Also Hertha TV macht in-house eine Doku und die ist ziemlich stark, muss ich sagen. Und die haben jetzt auch angefangen, die letzten Teile als Premiere im Kino zu machen, die waren ausverkauft. Gestern war eine Premiere in Neukölln, da ist dann auch Fabi Reza aufgelaufen. Das ist alles im Verein lief, das ist das erste Mal seit Jahren irgendwie gut, dass du das Gefühl hast, okay, man führt sich zusammen, es ist ein neues Wehgefühl da. Aber du hast jetzt auch – also Kai Bernstein am Anfang hätte eh geendet, jetzt zum Sommer, da wären neue Wahlen gewesen. Du hast immer noch die große Gefahr, dass der Investor irgendwie jemanden da findet, der genehmer gewesen wäre, so wie zum Beispiel Frank Steffel war, dem Lars Windhorst, glaube ich, ganz glücklich gewesen wäre. Also meine große Hoffnung ist, dass die Fans gesehen haben, was geht und sich das nicht mehr wegnehmen lassen. Dass ein neuer Status quo entsteht, so auch ein bisschen wie bei den DFL-Protesten, hast du ja auch gesehen, was die Fans können. Und dass man sich darauf ein bisschen mehr besinnt und versucht, das ein bisschen mehr in den Vordergrund zu bringen und nicht immer nach oben zu gucken. Spielerisch, es gibt großartige Leute. Ich meine, Pascal Clemens, der ist 19 Jahre alt, der hat fast alle Spiele gemacht, egal ob in der Verteidigung oder auf Sechs. Das macht er alles ganz easy, hat, glaube ich, in Hannover ein Tor geschossen. Das ist alles sehr schön. Du hast dann auch ein Kader, der kommt über das Argument, der Kader ist so teuer, der müsste doch eigentlich ganz oben sein. Der Kader hat lauter Altverträge. Kempf zum Beispiel, ich glaube, Kempf ist der bestverdienste Spieler in der zweiten Liga und dann hast du noch ein Kenny hier schon auch. Also alles, was aus der Bo-Bitch-Ära kommt, wird riesen krass alte Verträge haben. Deswegen werden die auch alle wahrscheinlich gehen müssen, auch egal wie gut du siehst. Ein Kenny hat sich super gemacht dieses Jahr, aber irgendwie es gibt keine wirkliche Entwicklung in dem Sinne, dass man es geschafft hat, irgendwas anderes aufzubauen, als ein Pass von hinten links einfach auf Reese und der guckt dann irgendwie. Du hast einen Tabakowitsch, der mal fünf Tore in zwei Spielen macht, aber so richtig lang zusammen geht es nicht. Du hast auf dem rechten Flügel ein bisschen das Problem, du hast einen Martin Winkler, der hat ganz okay angefangen und seitdem ist er irgendwie immer ein bisschen raus. Man weiß nicht so recht, was passiert und du hast dieses Mittelfeldproblem. Also wir haben früher immer in den Erstliga-Jahren davon gesprochen, von der Tore des sechstes Tore, des Todes, halt Doppelsechstes Todes, Fabian Lustenberger und Pierre Schellbrett. Was du da heute auf der Sechs hast, ist es einfach, das war die ganze Zeit auch immer die Achillesferse und deswegen wurden die Spieler auch im Grunde verloren, weil du im Mittelfeld nicht hinterher gekommen bist. Und da sehe ich noch keine so richtige Lösung.
Also auch Pascal Clemens kann das alleine nicht auf seinen Schultern tragen. Ich meine, wie gesagt, die sportliche Situation ist so in der Schwebe. Und dann haben wir ja aber als letztes ein großes Thema, also wir werden natürlich viel über die Mitgliederversammlung noch hören, die dann stattfinden wird in diesem Jahr noch. Aber dann haben wir natürlich noch Triple Seven und deren Einstieg. Da habe ich jetzt schon lange nichts mehr von gehört. Äußern die sich nicht? Bekommt man nicht raus, in welchem Sinne die mit Hertha zusammenarbeiten? Wann gibt es denn endlich die ersten Zugänge aus Genua und so weiter? Also was ist da der Stand?
Also sie setzen sich nicht bei BildTV hin wie Lars Windhorst. Und ich hoffe, dass Spors nicht zu Nius sich setzen wird. Heute kam ein bisschen was, also es gab immer schon, es soll im Sommer so gewesen sein, dass sie gerne gehabt hätten, dass Palldare nicht Trainer wird, sondern bei der Führung damals gelungen Palldare als Trainer durchzusetzen gegen Widerstand des Investors. Sie halten sich relativ zurück. Ich glaube, wir haben einen Spieler verliehen an Standard Lüttich. Das ist, glaube ich, einer der großen, wunderbaren Triple-Seven-Familien. Also sie machen es deutlich besser als Lars Windhorst, was im Grunde auch keine große ist.
Ich bin so schlecht im Zähnen, hätte es trotzdem besser gemacht als Lars Windhorst.
Sie halten sich zurück, aber ich glaube, da wird jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr hinter dem Kulissen ein bisschen Druck gemacht. Andererseits haben wir jetzt einen Weber als Sportdirektor, den ich jahrelang immer nur als Leiter der Akademie kannte. Und ich weiß noch, wie skeptisch wir alle waren. Es gab dann direkt nach dem Rauswurf von Bobic gab es so einen Termin, wo man sich anmelden konnte. 200 Fans wurden zugelassen. Dann saßen die da vorne, Kai, Zecke, Neuendorf und Benny Weber. Und wir haben uns gedacht, okay, was soll es. Aber mittlerweile hat er mit dem, was er hatte, eine super Transferphase hingelegt, was wir bekommen haben für wenig Geld. Du hast einen Tabakobestand, 5 Tore geschossen. Was ich nicht so weiß, was macht Dade aus dem Kader? Du hast ein paar Spiele, die hast du einfach nicht mehr gesehen. Du hast uns mal Treviac, der eigentlich immer ganz okay war. Den sehe ich immer auf dem Spielbogen als mit dabei, aber ich sehe ihn einfach nicht mehr. Dudziak ist schon länger wieder fit. Dudziak war ganz wichtig. Ich glaube, der war vereinzelt. Der kam von Fürz für umsonst, weil er in die Türkei ausgeliehen war. Und dann war er in der Erdbebenzone. Der kam aus dem richtigen Höllen. Der hat uns super toll angefangen. War ganz wichtig, das Spiel ein bisschen zu bewegen. Dann hat er einmal kurz gegen Kiel gespielt, hat fast noch das entscheidende Tor geschossen. Seitdem habe ich ihn nicht mehr gesehen. Dann hast du Karbovnik, den teuersten Transfer, der am Anfang okay war. An dieser linken Seite hast du Karbovnik. Letztes Jahr war er offenbar ein sehr guter Linksverteidiger bei Düsseldorf. Und ein Resa, das muss ja super, großartig laufen, aber irgendwie, der zeigt sich auch nicht mehr so richtig. Das ist schwierig. Am meisten verzweifelt man, dass es einmal ein Barcock ist, der sechs spielt, obwohl er achter oder zehnter ist. Und keiner weiß so richtig, warum. Ich hatte Szenen, wo ich dachte, das geht alles. Und es kann kein Dadeiball mehr. Die Jugendspieler kommen ja auch aus dem – die gewinnen ja fast alle ihre Spiele. Die haben ein Offensivspiel. Das ist nicht mehr dieses Marvin Plattenhardt-Ball kommt. Ich trete drauf, gucke erstmal nach hinten, gebe einen Pass nach hinten. Aber auch dann hast du Leute wie Maximilian Mittelstedt, der jahrelang es nicht schafft, am Plattenhardt vorbeizukommen und jetzt bei Stuttgart zum Nationalspieler wird.
Das tut natürlich weh. Nein. Das heißt, wie ist dein Ausblick? Also Aufstieg dann nächstes Jahr alternativlos. Und das wird dann auch klappen. Zusammen mit Hannover geht ihr rauf.
Und Kiel, hast du ja gesagt. Von daher, du hast ja alle drei Aufsteiger hier sitzen. Das ist ja 2025.
Da wird es dann endlich einer wieder in der Relegation schaffen. Gleich kann sich Kiel an Köln dann rächen. Das ist ja, aber gut, die Relegationsstories, die müssen wir jetzt noch nicht auspacken.
Wir können schon dieses Jahr hoch und dann habt ihr Platz für eins und zwei nächstes Jahr.
Na, siehste, da haben wir es doch. Dann können endlich auch mal, weißt du, erst kann Kiel hoch und dann dürfen die Investorenvereine auch. Das finde ich eigentlich eine schöne Reihenfolge. Muss ich sagen. Und dann gibt es auch kein 50 plus 1 mehr und dann ist...
Ja, Holstein hat ja in der Mitgliederversammlung letztes Jahr 50 plus 1 in die Satzung aufgenommen, nach Wunsch der Fans. Und deswegen, da sind wir nur ganz gut davor.
Ja, gut, aber also 50 plus 1 wackelt mehr als jemals zuvor. Aber ich bin gerade dran, hoffentlich gibt es da irgendwann ein Tribüngespräch dazu. Neugucken, vielleicht kommt mir auch die Realität zuvor, ehrlich gesagt. Das geht jetzt alles sehr, sehr schnell, wie 50 plus 1 gerade vor die Hunde geworfen wird von denjenigen, die 50 plus 1 hochhalten müssten. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Ja, bei uns gibt es aber auch noch die Satzungskommission, noch von Kai Bernstein einberufen. Da ist man dran. Und ich habe auch in diesem DFL-Investorenprozess gesehen. Ich glaube, früher mit einem Ingo Schiller und einem Michael Prez, da hätte Hertha öffentlich gesagt, wir wissen nicht. Und die hatten sofort mit Ja geschrieben. Jetzt sind wir ein klares Nein. Das ist auch schon mal ein großer Fortschritt. Und das ist halt für dich als Fan, was du gerade erlebst, ist der Verein hält zusammen. Es ist wirklich diese Familie und nicht dieses Lalalala-Abschiedskultur. Also ich habe dieses Tribütengespräch gehört und es war hart.
Für das Produkt als Verein war Hannover auch ein klares Nein.
Stimmt, wir haben ja hier die Investoren. Feinde sitzen quasi, die gleichzeitig Investorenvereine sind. Das ist der wunderbare Fußball. Solche Geschichten schreibt dann tatsächlich nur mal der Fußball in dem Sinne. Aber das heißt quasi abschließend, ich habe das Gefühl, Jan, es ist eine Saison in der Schwebe. Viele Dinge nerven, vor allem die Rückrunde. Viele Dinge tun weh. Natürlich, Kai Bernstein und die Ungewissheit, was jetzt kommt, ist auch so. Aber Hertha hat sich schon in diesem relativ kurzen Zeitraum des Wirkens von Kai Bernstein und eben auch von Menschen wie eben Pardada, der später sicherlich eine Rolle, auch Benni Weber, zu sich gefunden. Und das wird jetzt nicht von einer, sagen wir es wie es ist, beschissenen Rückrunde irgendwie rausgerissen, sondern wenn da jetzt nicht was ganz Schlimmes passiert, geht man irgendwie aus dieser Saison raus. Ganz viele Ungewissheiten bleiben, aber man bleibt auch bei sich.
Es hängt halt sehr viel von dieser Mitgliederversammlung ab. Also, dann ist ja die Frage, wer dann Präsident wird. Wenn das etwas investorenfreundlicheres wird, dann kann das alles sehr schnell wieder zurückkippen. Aber im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr ist es wirklich ein – also, wenn wir jetzt den Tod von Kai Beinstein ausklammern würden, wäre es eigentlich ein okayes Jahr. Und ich bin zufällig bei Stadion Check auf den Blog geraten vor ein paar Tagen. Der hatte im Mai geschrieben, als hätte er abgestiegen, weil er wünscht, dass er mal ein ganz ruhiges Jahr im Mittelfeld hat.
Sehr gut. Ja, es sind die kleinen Dinge. Und die muss man sich auch gewöhnen. Woran ich mich nie gewöhnen werde, ist, dass diese Sendungen immer viel zu kurz sind. Aber ich kann auch nichts machen irgendwann. Aber ihr drei, das hat große Freude gemacht, mit euch über eure Vereine zu sprechen. Und auch immer wieder interessant, ich dachte nicht, dass es diesmal so viele Parallelen gibt, aber so ein paar habe ich dann doch erkannt. Und ich glaube, die Hörerinnen und Hörer auch. Also ich danke euch drei sehr herzlich. Ganz herzlichen Dank, Pike. Schön, dass du mal wieder da warst. Herzlichen Dank für den völlig ironiefreien Ansgar. Danke dir.
Immer wieder.
Und danke, Jan. Schön, dass du hier warst im Rasenfunk. Ja, mit euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke ich natürlich auch. Es gibt zwei Dinge, die ich noch abkündigen möchte, bevor ich euch entlasse in die sonstigen Podcasts, die ihr so hören wollt. Das eine ist etwas Persönliches und zwar, wir brauchen ein neues Rasenfunk Headquarter. Ich wurde leider auf Eigenbedarf gekündigt. Drohe Geschichte, kann man auch nichts gegen machen. Bisschen belastend, aber ihr könnt mir dabei helfen. Ich suche jetzt neue Vermieter und ich brauche nette Vermieter auf nette-vermieter-gesucht.de. Da könnt ihr erfahren, was ich suche in München und wo ich suche in München und da kann man mir auch helfen, indem man diese Seite teilt, indem ihr alle euren Kontakte schickt. Wir brauchen irgendjemanden, der einfach sagt, ich will nur einen netten Mieter. Dann verzichte ich vielleicht auch auf den einen oder anderen Euro und dann komme ich ins Spiel. Also geht bitte auf diese Seite nette-vermieter-gesucht.de, jeweils mit einem Minus dazwischen, werde es auch verlinken und dann bedanke ich mich aber natürlich bei euch allen, die meine Miete bisher bezahlen, auch wenn die jetzt exorbitant steigen wird. Und in dieser Folge danke ich FrankyPanky, Michael, Carlito1904, Nina und Alex, René und Lisa R. Sie alle unterstützen uns nicht nur finanziell auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club, sondern sie alle haben sich auch registriert dort. Und deswegen kann ich euch hier nach dem Zufall das Prinzip danken. Und unterstützen könnt ihr uns via PayPal, Kreditkarte, alles Mögliche geht. Jetzt schaltet uns der Zahlungsdienstleister sogar noch klar nach frei, obwohl wir nie danach gefragt haben. Also es gibt wirklich keine Ausreden, es nicht zu tun. Und alles, was wir hier tun, wird von euch finanziert. Und keine Angst, nicht nur meine Miete, auch die Gäste kriegen einen Honorar und so weiter und so fort. In diesem Sinne, Dank für euren Support. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund, ciao!
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.